they block the main highway outside
quito residents of san miguel de
calderon say president guillermo lasso
who has been in office for four months
lied to them during the election
campaign about fixing the troubled
economy and improving their lives
they say his recent decision to raise
fuel prices proves it this woman does
not want to show her face she's a nurse
and says ecuadorians are struggling to
survive
i make 400 a month and i cannot make it
to the end of the month the president
increases the price of fuel and this
affects us in every possible way
it wasn't long before the police and
armed forces marched in
the president declared a state of
emergency a week ago to combat rising
crime and protests are not tolerated
the police are using tear gas and rubber
bullets to clear the roads now they're
going into
this community and going after the
protesters the protesters are saying
that president guillory's banker that is
hurting their interests and that's why
they remain on the streets
the government says demonstrators are
trying to generate chaos but those
protestings say they just want the price
of fuel frozen
along with indigenous communities who
want a halt in government plans to
increase oil and mining production
they also want the police to stop using
tear gas to break up the protest
my grandchildren are inside one is two
months old they can't breathe they are
throwing gas inside my house
several people were detained and others
were injured during the clashes in san
miguel de calderon
president guillermo lasso is heading to
glasgow this week to participate in the
cop26 climate meeting
but people here want him to look at
what's affecting them directly in the
community
we don't have work we are poor there are
no millionaires here we all suffer here
there is no water no electricity
lasso came to power with a promise to
improve the economy and has been trying
to pass a series of business friendly
laws that will help him get out of the
current crisis
he's now asking equatorials to unite
i'm calling for dialogue consensus to
think about what's good for our country
not in personal interests while we
rebuild ecuador there are people who
want to divide it but people have lost
trust in the administration
they say the government's development
plans do not include people like them
san miguel de calderon